my name is John Folse I'm director of
user interface technologies a Wolfram
research and I'm going to be talking
today about this state of the front-end
in 2019
thank you okay so we're gonna go ahead
and get started here I think there's
still a few people filtering in my name
is John Fults I'm with the user
interface group wolfram research I am
tied in to all the stuff with notebook
front end which is what I'm gonna be
talking about today also tied into a
bunch of our mobile development which
I'm not going to be talking about today
but we do have a couple talks coming up
parth Pratap and nicks it's Minh are
gonna be talking this afternoon right
and about our mobile ecosystem and then
there's gonna be another talk tomorrow
bye
robbery case go field Jason Harris
tomorrow afternoon right about about the
player and some of the technology that
we have for that not going to focus on
those just at the moment but I did want
to just announce them so you know that
they're there so what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to talk about call out a few
things that are coming in version 12.1
that's what you're interested in
yeah I'll mention just a little bit of
the past two but and but we have a lot
of projects in motion and I'm unlike
Stephen and the way he gives his talks
which are like a survey of everything it
seems that's happening throughout the
entire company there is a lot of stuff
that's happening I'm not going to cover
if I didn't hit your favorite topic it's
talk to me or talk to we have a bunch of
front-end people here talk to anyone but
one of us so the single biggest thing
that's been occupying our thoughts and
based on user feedback has been
occupying a lot of your thoughts to is
high DPI supports and especially under
windows and so this is something that we
and putting a lot of effort into for for
version 12:1 and it's it's not a one-off
sort of thing it's not even just for
windows it's it's really something that
it's a system that we're building for
the future and it dealt with a lot of
legacy stuff some of which is good to
talk about here because in the previous
talk one of the things that came up was
how far back do we support stuff some of
the stuff that's like in mass source or
old notebooks or whatever and kind of
how long we support that and and some of
the high DPI stuff has not major
consequences but noticeable consequences
for some of the how we have handled the
long term support and compatibility of
notebooks so with that let's get started
so this this has been an assumption that
has been embedded in the notebook
front-end since since 1996 and maybe
even earlier but 1996 was kind of a
reset of the front-end and the notion
that there is a correlation between
pixels and linear distance and a pixel
is 170 seconds of an inch if you know
anything about the print world you will
recognize that number that's the same
size as a printers point so not pulled
out of nowhere and so this is an
assumption that we embedded into the
front end a very long time ago in a day
and age when when we've then built a lot
of assumptions on top of it and so just
to emphasize the point here's a here's a
one inch by one inch pixel grid 72
pixels on a side visualized and I'm just
gonna zoom in on that for purposes of
exploring a bit of what we're talking
about in this case it's a 1/6 by 1/6
inch pixel grid 12 pixels on a side
so one of the big things that happened a
few years ago was in the in the world of
Apple machines where they released what
they called their retina technology and
retina was was literally a pixel
doubling or doubling in each dimension
there are four times as many pixels but
twice as many in each dimension and so
we released a retina retinal version of
our product and I forget exactly which
release it was but if a few years ago
and we we had to revisit some of our old
assumptions but there were certain you
know the fact that everything was an
even doubling sort of made things easy
for us we dealt with some of the
problems but didn't really deal with all
the problems at the time and and so in
this case this is our pixel grid 24
pixels on a side same in principle same
linear distance same linear dimensions
so now on the windows side it's
interesting because windows if you from
a programmers perspective you've been
able to query what the monitor
resolution is under windows and windows
has been telling us 96 dpi since windows
95 and and well there weren't really any
96 dpi monitors back then but if the
windows wasn't looking at the monitor it
just said you're running a 96 dpi
monitor so Windows was kind of lying to
us but it was a number that Microsoft
chose they have the reasons for choosing
it they felt that they felt that it was
good to actually specify kind of a
tighter resolution because because that
had the effect actually of making things
a bit larger and so if you specify a
12-point font you're looking at it on a
screen and especially you know the
screen
technologies of the day I mean it'd be a
little bigger help the readability
compared to for example the printed page
Macintosh at the time was saying 72 dpi
and so we had to make some sort of
decision and the decision that we made
was we're just going to say 72 dpi as
well and so the state of affairs in 1996
was you know if you held a ruler up to
the screen a lot of monitors I mean they
weren't uniform but a lot of monitors
actually we're at 72 dpi so so in 1996
Macintosh was right we were right you
know in some technical terms Windows was
wrong you know if you're going to
compare to what what the ruler on the
screen actually says well that was yeah
that was a long time ago state of
affairs now in version 12 has flipped
completely and interestingly the no and
here I had to change the table a little
bit I'm specifying now typical low res
monitors because the situation gets
different with high res monitors but
when I say a typical low res monitor I
mean the kind of monitor that you're
buying for seventy five dollars at Best
Buy and so even those are now actually
typically 96 dpi that's about right and
so Microsoft read the future well on
that one and Apple well they have the
reality distortion field so in their
universe it is 72 dpi I'm sure but but
our assumption looks problematic and
it's people have noticed this on stack
has changed and sometimes you'll see
questions oh I make a 12-point font in
Mathematica and it doesn't look like a
12-point font in other applications even
though the magnification is 100% and you
you know looks like I'm comparing apples
to apples so be it
so this is where we're going to be four
twelve one which is for the typical
low-res monitors Windows says 96 dpi and
Mac says 72 dpi and we say arguably
maybe what we should have done a long
time ago but these you know you know
these decisions get made but now we're
saying trust the OS and we kind of have
to do that and we have to do that
because in 1996 people were just
completely inventing these numbers you
know Microsoft has just had you know 96
hard-coded somewhere and always
returning it that's not true anymore
these days there's actually some in the
case of Microsoft beginning with Windows
7 and then really kind of strengthening
into Windows 10 where Microsoft and the
hardware vendors who work with Microsoft
have some real intelligence about about
what the default settings should be and
then of course Apple has retina and only
two choices in Apple right now but who
knows what Apple might do in the future
you know Apple might decide that retina
isn't good enough and we need a super
retina and if you look at what's
happened in the world of iOS there is
such a proposition doesn't seem
ridiculous so good to be prepared for
that
so trust the OS is is what is happening
in 12-1 but this has a consequence this
has a few consequences and so one is the
here's here's a 96 dpi grid and a 72 dpi
grid and they don't look like one
another they don't look anything like
one another at all and they happen to
both be divisible by 12 there's at least
that but but that's not necessarily very
helpful and it gets worse
because we're just looking at low res
monitors here there are a number of
people who have this is what's what
Microsoft calls 100% scaling
if you go into your operating system
settings there's there's a display
setting that allows you to change the
scaling it's set to a default according
to your particular hardware by the way
may be different from monitor to monitor
it might not be the same for all the
monitors that are simultaneously hooked
up to your system but so the one of the
kind of worst-case scenarios is the is
the 125 percent scaling which is 120 dpi
and one of the things that we've been
thinking a lot is is the the greatest
common factor of a bunch of these
numbers because they keep coming up for
us so this means then that if we look at
our 12 point grid with all the pixels
the same size that 96 dpi that the 12
point grid is physically larger here on
the monitor and so and notice that I I
started using the word points here
pixels and points and that's what we
have to think about are we talking about
pixels are we talking about points and
so the so what's happening here is then
as a result if we're going to draw a 12
point character we're gonna get
something like this and this isn't just
for fonts it has broader consequences
throughout the system but what this
means is that if if it's trust the OS
then then we're gonna have a
compatibility issue and when I say
compatibility I don't mean in that
broken files or something like that but
I mean things are gonna look different
and that's a consequence of a decision
we made for better or worse a long time
ago but but that's where we're at so if
you're comparing in version 12 and
version 12 one on Macintosh looks the
same because Macintosh is telling us 72
or in the case of Retina 1/4
for dpi but in the case of Windows
things are going to look different now
we did try to in order to make this not
too bad for people who have low res
monitors we do have a legacy setting so
12 oh and 12 1 looked the same and low
res monitors is kind of the worst case
scenario because you have fewer pixels
and if you're what all your windows get
bigger but if if your screen scaling is
anything other than a hundred percent
which basically means you have some form
of high DPI high resolution monitor then
we're going with what the monitors tells
or with what the operating system tells
us and so that's the consequence some
people love it I wear progressive lenses
because I'm getting older and I love it
other people are like we love their
fonts tiny and tinier would have been
better and so it's difficult to get a
universal agreement on this but that's
where we're at this has some other
consequences too and some of them you
might not have thought of if you do any
programming with the front end the good
news is that we documented things the
correct way almost everywhere in the
documentation we said points we didn't
say pixels we said points and kind of
breathing a sigh of relief about that
one because that's what we're committing
to now
so before pixels and points were
effectively the same but that's not true
anymore
if you specify not just the font size
but if you specify a window size window
size is no longer in pixels in fact even
under retina in the shipping versions it
wasn't technically in pixels either but
we were kind of saying well it's just a
doubling so that's we can kind of wave
that away we can't wave it away anymore
because it's not a simple factor so the
that means that when you look at you
know any of these these the options I've
listed here
most common ones you're going to run
across window size and window margins
affecting notebooks image size image
margins you know the various sizes and
margins and margins sort of options and
then anything that refers to absolute
coordinates thickness and point size and
dashing those are all absolutely offset
is also an absolute based coordinate
system and these have always been
documented in points now what should be
the case though is that as long as you
didn't embed in your code any
assumptions about points things may get
bigger but they should get bigger
uniformly so it's you know there wasn't
really the case as we were going through
here that we you know that we did a lot
that made any kind of assumption about
oh it's one pixel there were a few cases
we had to be careful of where we had we
did some things like and mostly it was
like drawing a one pixel thick line and
this came up a little bit with tick
marks and things like cell brackets and
a few cases where we just you know we
wanted to be able to draw one pixel
thick line and nail it to the pixel grid
and so there were a few things for us
but I don't think as long as you had the
right assumptions before I don't think
it will generally be a problem oh and
there if you do notebook programming
there are lots of options you would find
in the option inspector too that I
didn't list cell level notebook level
options so and then just a little bit
more in terms of how we explore this and
a few people among the beta testers have
reported this and kind of had some head
scratching where well I did system
information in version 12 and I did
system information in
you know in the 12 on beta and it looks
very different and yeah so the in in my
case I ran this on a surface book 2
which is a 200% scaling so so it
basically dropped down by a factor of
well not just one half because it also
had to navigate the 72 versus 96 dpi and
then we we added a current value which
is more discriminating in terms of the
kind of information that it can return
about monitors so pixel constrained as
an option is there wasn't really
anything we can do with that we're just
gonna have to deprecated raster sighs we
won't deprecated but I wouldn't
recommend using it i raster size is one
thing that's documented to be in pixels
and it's much better I think to go with
the you know the alternative options
image size and image resolution which I
think do would do what you want if
you're doing beta testing if you're
getting baited from the conference
there's still a little bit of work that
we're doing on image and rasterize to
push this all the way through that
that's the biggest part of my talk I
wanted to get into a few other things
that I want to call out things that are
in motion and that that I'm this one is
not that certain to be in 12-1 I'm
hoping it will be but we'll see we've
spent a lot of work on updating our our
3d rendering engines you to is going to
be talking about this tomorrow afternoon
along with some very exciting shader
technology and some other stuff that he
wants to show but but the big thing here
in among Mac crowd people have been
asking for for metal for ages well it's
become increasingly clear that Apple has
no interest in OpenGL anymore they have
an updated OpenGL and years and so so we
are making the transition we're also
updating our windows layer so
I want to talk a little bit about
Wolfram Alpha notebooks and I'm not
going to go into huge detail about the
Wolfram Alpha notebook edition product
but there will be a talk in a training
session later about that I have info on
that on my next slide but but I just
wanted to it's a really exciting product
I think and it's something that my group
was very interested in because a lot of
the you know it's really two pieces of
technology coming together like the like
the old Reese's Peanut Butter Cup
commercials the Wolfram Alpha and
notebooks and and my group and
especially Lou D'Andrea I don't know if
he's here did a lot of work on this and
and so we have notebooks that you know
that can do some very fancy things let
me pop up the magnification notice a bit
and it's and so this is basically it's
just like the notebook experience except
it's you know the plain English inputs
the and it has you know some notion of
kind of linearity I'm just it figures
out what I want to plot because it was
the previous thing that was there it's
also taking a look at inputs and saying
well we have a predictive interface for
outputs but it also adds a predictive
interface for inputs which is cool
because outputs can be sometimes
reductive about your exploration and so
being able to examine the inputs and in
this cases you know do something like
that where it's figuring out how to
solve for the zeros there it's very cool
so this is a standalone product that
that we kind of scoped to be limited for
a particular audience but I don't think
that these notebooks are limited to the
standalone product because the
and we just didn't quite get it ready in
time for 12:00 Oh but in 12:1 this is we
have these you know wolfram alpha mode
notebook here as well and this this is a
statement that I wanted to make sure
everyone understood is that although it
is a different kind of product you know
there's one world of notebooks and it's
always gonna be the case that anything
we do you know notebooks here in
notebooks there everything works in
every product that we show and so this
is it's not the case that there is like
a Wolfram Alpha notebook format that's
somehow different from everything else
and that's something that I've pushed
very hard for I think it's kind of you
know it's it's part of what we do as a
company is you know we have a grand
unified vision for these things so more
about that and and by the way this was
technology that was built largely using
you know the wulfing off a notebook
product was built largely using the
stuff that we shipped I mean it's I I
can't give you a loo D'Andrea to work on
it but I get but all the technology that
he used is in the product that you have
today I'm running low on time so I may
end up having to cut a little bit at the
end but I wanted to call out completions
and this is something that is kind of
cool that we've been working on and it's
not on in the betas yet but it will be
soon and basically the idea is it's it's
if you've played with some of the modern
programming editors this is a very hip
thing to do where that you know you
don't have to type in necessarily
everything in order you know all of the
things in sequence that it can kind of
figure out you know if I type in Li PL
that sounds like maybe I'll list plot or
let's play or let's plot 3d just had a
three after that and and now it's given
me a new set of choices that works with
that or you know I can you know
something like B uch and that gets me
straight to bubble charts stuff that
kind of thing and this is I mean we hear
people saying that there's really cool
stuff going on modern editors that we
want to see in the book front end we do
too so and here's just a little bit
about how that works I need to speed it
along so I won't go into that
and I also wanted to call out really
quickly and this is something that's
easy to overlook is we have we have the
hyperlink interface was always really
kind of terrible and old and from 19
straight out of 1996 and so we have
something better now that's that you
know it's much easier to use it supports
it supports auto detection and so on and
and it will figure out you know editing
no problem if you don't like our auto
detection you can just mouse over over
and edit it and remove the link and
there you go and so that's just a few
things that I want to mention I don't
have time for questions I don't think
but but I'm happy to talk to anyone
afterwards so thank you very much
you